this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am john
deloney joined here by best-selling
author
brilliant friend and a pretty good mom
miss rachel cruz hope you're doing well
rachel
john always good to be here you're
pretty good at it it's pretty good
give me like a six out of ten you know i
wasn't gonna go six i was going to go
five
six is on the on the other side i'm
generous
you're doing pretty good so we're gonna
we're gonna take your calls if you've
got relationship questions money
questions
marriage questions whatever anything and
everything in between give us a shout
at it's 825-5225 eight eight two five
five two two five rachel how are we
doing
pretty good uh we had a fun little chat
right before we got on the air yeah
should we do it
yeah okay so john and i so again we'll
take all your questions money
relationships marriage parenting
and both of our our sets of kids
obviously we always talk about kids and
they're just
funny kids are funny they're crazy and
wild and they're funny
uh so we said okay let's do two truths
isn't a lie from just this week
things your kids have said okay go first
do i do all three
yeah okay i might have like just a
little bit of commentary with each one
bring it um so is this the truth or
we have truth or lie um yesterday
i went to get in the van and my
three-year-old caroline had had a
sharpie
and drew on the seat of our van
and i went through and told her that mom
was frustrated and i was mad i was like
caroline frustrated and angry i was like
mom you know i was like okay
i'm not mad that like the stuff is
ruined stuff is going to get lost stuff
is going to break
stuff is going to get ruined in our
lives our joy is not in our stuff
it's the fact that mommy and daddy work
really hard and mom's about to leave for
work
to work really hard to make money to buy
things
in our lives think nice things like this
van this was very expensive this was a
lot of money
and we want to take care of our things
and the three-year-old looks at me and
says
i want a snack i'm gonna go with the
truth on that one uh truth yeah
uh number two we moved caroline from a
crib to a big girl bed
uh three weeks ago one night we tried
keeping her in the room with a lot of
different theories of how to keep her in
and she appeared outside or beside our
bed five times in one night
and the last time i said carolyn you
have to stay in your room and she looked
at me she said i will always get out
[Laughter]
if you know rachel that came directly
from your soul
you've recreated yourself
congratulations that's for sure true
actually it was a false it was the
story's all true but she didn't say that
she just
kept coming down oh man i won i did win
and then the last truth was walking to
school three days ago it's all caroline
stories
yes uh and we had across the sidewalk
across the street to walk to school and
she refused to
she refused to move and i'm in the
middle with all this you know school
traffic people
oh yeah and i'm like i have charles in
the stroller i'm like we have to go
caroline kelly come on come on
and she just stood there i will not come
and i was like why are you protesting me
right now
there's all these people looking at us
please come so she did say that a fellow
instagram eight in your life makes me
happy oh my god because that's what
that's what the
cruise ramsey family needs is another
one it's another idea
there's another challenger in our lives
because we don't we don't have one in
the family yet okay so
um so we have we're pretty routine
driven in my house just
because my wife has to live with me and
so every night we were putting josephine
to get
bed and and my son hank and i went i
told josephine i was by myself this
night because sheila was bringing hank
home from the little game and
i told her hey go brush your teeth and
then i'm going to come in and
kiss you good night yeah and so i
started walking in there
and she was hanging on her um bunk bed
and i walked in and she said hey daddy
when you come in to kiss me
i'm going to jump off this and kick you
in the face
that is true i've never heard joseph
yeah that super happened
okay or or and
you know that my feelings for a second
like why are you gonna kiss me in the
face and then i actually thought
right then in her room one day
somebody's gonna lean in
and say i'm gonna kiss you i'm gonna
kiss you and she's gonna remember nope
i'm gonna kick you in the face
um or i said hey josephine
come here i've gotta brush her hair and
she's like no and i said
justin please come here so we can brush
your hair like we've got to do this
and she looked at me with this like
tearful frustration
and she said and i quote but daddy i'm
an owl
i had no response to that i didn't know
what to say i saw something a kid would
say
i don't know true i would think okay so
now it's a lie
but go what was your what's your name i
just had three truths i don't know how
to play this game
okay the the lie is she looked at me and
said daddy you're the best
that's the lie there's a lie that's a
lot mom you're the greatest mom in the
entire world she did
we love everything you do she did and my
daughter's five by the way she did come
in the other day and say hey dad i just
need you
like daddy mommy's my favorite pair to
which i was like that's great she's
she's clearly the best and then she said
and i love hank more than you
and i said you know what he's great and
then she said and i love stella more
than you who by the way is our dog still
is a dog
and i just it's cool man it's cool none
of these that we talked about none of
this in grad school by the way
it's ridiculous that's it
god love it okay no so we're great at
parenting obviously so just
so going back to the original comment
rachel's pretty good at this
yeah i on the other hand am not um okay
so we are taking your calls on life
and we are taking your calls on money
we're taking your calls
on anything that you want to talk about
triple 825
5225 rachel um
in all seriousness you have your oldest
one's five is that right
just turned six just turned six yeah a
few weeks ago and you've all the way
down to how old's charles now
18 months 18 months what's the biggest
shocker for you
like your pre-picture the picture you
had if this is what life is gonna be
like with three kids
now you've got three six to 18 months
it's just amazing how three kids can
feel like 21 kids
to me yes so like one kid i've realized
it's so unfortunate because when you
have your first kid you're that straight
you're stressed out you don't know what
you're doing
and you're like oh the question is am i
doing this right so you're so you are
stressed
when you look back you're like it's like
an accessory like one kid is like
just put it on my head and just go yeah
i can go
two kids you're like all right this is
like the d like i gotta
you gotta figure out and then you just
throw that third one in and suddenly
they just
multiply yeah when you go from man to
man to zone it gets all hard
yeah it's been it's been intense it's
been intense so what's your favorite
part of having three kids
um i think i i have
i love obviously we can't control this
but i love that i've had each gender
so the two girls and then a boy so i
love
as a mom my heart towards charles
is so different than the girls like it
just you just feel the stuff you love
your son more than your daughter a
little bit i mean he's kind of my
favorite right now
hey james and kelly if you'll clip that
and just said it to me
i'm kidding girls if you listen to this
in 30 years it's a joke they're going to
listen to it this weekend so i'm going
to send it to him
if y'all clip that that'd be fantastic
no but a little i don't know i just i
didn't think my heart's
it's amazing that your heart just
whether boy or girl each kid you're like
oh my gosh
i still like would literally jump in
front of a car for you right now right
now like
that i would it's amazing the pre-kid
thing for me
was this idea that you know it's gonna
be an accessory it's gonna be a thing to
do
if if i had known then what i know now
which is
i did i had another level of in my heart
for capacity for love i didn't know i
didn't know that existed yeah
and all of a sudden you look at this kid
and then they start talking to you and
they start laughing with you
and suddenly yeah you've got this whole
other part of you that i didn't know
existed
totally i love it it's awesome i love it
and by the way you can have both my kids
if you like them too
hey we're taking your calls on life and
money triple eight two five five
two two five this is john delaney with
my good friend rachel cruz and we'll be
right back here on the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
joined here with best-selling author
rachel cruz and we're taking your calls
on life and money at
in 825-5225 minnesota matthew what's
going on
hey how you guys doing thanks for taking
my call you bet what's going on man how
can we help
oh yes so i'm trying to make a long
story short i'm just trying to
get the best advice just coming from my
heart and everything
but me and my wife we've been married
six years
in the last about three or four years of
wanting to do the baby steps
she has been very um
she will agree to things we'll set an
agreement and then
she will just break the agreement
um now she's getting very uh house
hungry
so i am been wanting to pay off debt um
and then get an emergency fund and get a
house
um i've been even willing to compromise
uh go
50 50. uh she'll agree to it and then
she'll change her mind and then when i
ask her about it she'll tell me
it's you can do whatever you would like
to do
so what's your question man so so i
guess
just on how to um
as far as uh what to do in this
situation as far as
um just be getting more on the same page
with life and money goals
yeah um just for
the reason uh i've tried everything and
i feel like i am
sort of at the end of my rope because i
just feel like we can never compromise
yeah so matthew even though so for her
when you guys set something together and
she says okay yeah i'll do that and then
she doesn't do it what is her main
reason for not doing it
and what are the goals is it she's not
living on a budget is it that
you want to pay off this debt and you
need this amount of money in the bank to
do that but then she spends it like what
what are the things that you're trying
to do that she
is saying she will do and then she
doesn't
um so we have wrote out a budget
together
she agrees that will look that that
looks good that looks good um
but then she'll come back to me and say
i don't really like the budget
um i will give her um say i'll give her
like
100 more spending than me i mean i'm
very generous of what i'm
doing just to work together more
but she just comes back at me and says i
don't want to do it i can't live my life
like this and why
matthew why why can she not do why is it
because
she wants to spend whatever she wants
she doesn't want you be accountable to
you
why ah she feels very
controlling even though i say it's not
being controlling it's about controlling
our money um
of where it's going so that we can reach
our goals well i'll be curious what you
say because even matthew i'll be i'll
i'll i'll
be on her side for just a split second
matthew because i even heard you say i
give her an extra
hundred dollars you know so so you have
a pronoun problem there matt
that this is that you this is your house
and your money that you're willing to
share with her
she'll get on board with you and that
may not be what's happening but that's
the language you're using
and it was enough that me and rachel
both went
right is this happening in other areas
of your life besides the budget
uh yeah there's been some trust uh
issues with me i've been going to
therapy for it
i started having feelings for a
co-worker more of like a
work wife type of thing um i've gone to
therapy for it
um i feel like that's another part where
she can't forgive me nothing
physically happen but just having those
feelings
for that so i think that was another
big issue and i've been working on it
well my guess here is that
was fruit that was
grown on a tree of a relationship that's
had cracks and fissures and all sorts of
communication challenges and unmet needs
and all we could unpack that all day
at the end of the day it sounds like
your wife has had to do
what many many folks in relationships
have to do
or feel they have to do is they start
creating an alt universe
for their own safety for their own space
because they don't feel safe where
they're at
they either don't have trust in their
partner they don't feel like that
their husband or wife is um telling the
truth they're going to be there for them
whatever the narrative may be
they've just got to start creating
another universe and then when somebody
like you shows up
once a month and says hey here's how
you're going to spend your money
man she's already created another world
and so what i would tell you is your
marriage is on life support right now
not because you did what because you had
a
you know a relationship with somebody at
work
but because man there's deep seated
challenges in the roots of this thing
and it's you're going to focus on that
particular issue you're going to focus
on the fact that your budget's not
all of that is fruit of a tree that's
dying okay
and so what i want to tell you is you'll
need to get into counseling together
and not for you to go work on a thing
you all need to get there together and
get to the bottom of your relational
disconnection there brother
um this is an issue that sounds like
it's about money it's not
it's about something that's always going
to say it's amazing how many
life problems marriage problems
masquerade themselves as money problems
right it's not a budget problem and
matthew hit it around the head and i
appreciate your honesty
i appreciate you just saying it because
i know the regret in your voice and the
decisions you made um
but being it but it is a process lisa
turkish i heard her say was forgiveness
it's a decision and a process
there you go you can decide to do it but
man it can be a process
and as john said i mean yes
going to therapy together will be huge
and for her to go on her own she has a
lot she has a road that she has to heal
on matthew i mean like that that is very
real um
and you do as well so there's just a lot
of work to do under the surface and then
the beautiful thing is the fruit
of that when you guys work on that
together separate and then together in
the marriage
then things like a money issue or a
parenting issue come up and you're on
the same team
but you're not gonna be able to get at
this point a budget together
uh and working together on your money
it's probably not going to happen
it's not going to happen soon you guys
have to work on your marriage first so i
get this i get this question a lot
rachel
on my show i want to walk you through
matthew what this is going to look like
this is going to look like you telling
your wife hey i wanna have a
conversation about a future
and it's a positive one that way she
doesn't think oh no it's coming
um and i wanna do that tomorrow night i
wanna do that
tomorrow morning i like i like morning
meetings because people aren't tired i
like breakfast ones
some people anthony everybody likes to
have dinner hard conversations
and i want you to take your wife out
somewhere that you get out of the side
of your house it's a new environment
it's a new context and i want you to
tell her
i love you and i want this marriage to
work and i think there's a lot of
challenges that are
all through this thing um would you be
willing to
go to counseling with me to go see
somebody and
not that we gotta fix this and fix that
that's broken i need you to do this
better but no no no we need to get to
the bottom of this thing and say
how can we excavate what was because
y'all got to build something new
um the the analogy is always the twin
towers right you can't
take all that glass and twisted metal
and
rebuild those same towers with those
materials you got to clean the whole
thing out
get an architect get new engineers
design something beautiful and new
that's actually stronger than what was
right so it's this is a this is a cool
moment but it's a hard moment and see if
she is willing to rebuild something from
the floor up with you man
from the basement and i would say it's
it's it's an encouraging process even
though
um it's a lot of work so you can say
this on the marriage and you can say
this with your money those of you
listening that want to
do better with your money man it's a it
is a process to learn
new habits to learn new skills to learn
new ways of communication
to learn you know on the budget on the
money side how to budget i mean like
right
it's all these things that you're
learning that are new you gotta grieve
the crap and mistakes you you
you did in the past 100 yes the shame
and the guilt are gonna keep kind of
knocking on the door and and dealing
with that but
but gosh the work it's a lot of work
it's a lot of pain
it's a lot of being uncomfortable it's
not fun all the time
but you're doing good work like just
because it's hard doesn't mean it's
wrong
almost almost the reverse the the harder
it gets the more you know
in the yes and then in the depth of the
change matthew in your marriage
and then as a result working as a team
and winning financially it's just like a
cherry on top right as kind of a branch
off of that
it's a beautiful thing and all of you
listening like that can be that's the
story that's that's why we do the ramsay
show is for redemption
whether it's your marriage your
parenting your money you can change the
way you've been doing things
you could take those bricks out of your
backpack that you carry and you can
begin to pave a new road with them and
that road
is what your kids are going to walk on
that's what your community is going to
walk on this stuff isn't lost i love
that word redeem you redeem that
nonsense from the past
man you built something totally new so
matthew ball's in your court brother
hope you'll take her out um tonight take
her out tomorrow
and say are you if you're all in i'm all
in and we're gonna do this together
and it's gonna start with me going to
counseling and building something new
it's your call man thanks for
vulnerability and your bravery we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show and on the debt
free stage is david and courtney and it
looks like
it doesn't look like there's only one
reason y'all are on that stage you're
debt-free
yes congrats guys amazing so
tell us your story how much debt have
you guys paid off um so
my now husband we just got married
tuesday um
tuesday is this your honeymoon it is yes
oh my gosh
i'm so yeah so a couple years ago um
i found the financial piece university
was offered through my work
and i was like okay this is great and
he's actually in the financial realm so
he's been telling me all these finance
tips and stuff i'm like that doesn't
make any sense i don't understand
um and then i found the financial piece
and i started to go to these classes and
i was like oh my gosh david
you don't understand like these are so
close i've literally been telling you
these things i'm like
yeah but he said in a way that i
understood and i was like i like it
because
like the dave ramsey program not just
only told me how to manage my money but
like how god told us how we should
manage our money
so how much did you pay off um thirteen
thousand and seventy five dollars
and how long did it take you 11 months
girl you did it yeah in less than a
month you're like i'm doing it
oh yeah actually there was it was
supposed to take a lot longer but it was
just
you know being diligent putting anything
that came our way towards it it was
money came up in ways i didn't think of
like christmas or
you know birthday stuff like that you
don't think about it was just oh
here's another 200 here's another 200
and it
it actually cut back the time to take to
pay off by like six months oh wow
isn't that funny i've heard so many
people on the stage or doing these calls
say that they say and then i got a raise
or then i ended up with this amount of
money like it's just it's
it's so interesting and i feel like that
can happen in our life but we're not
when we're not intentional with it it
just kind of floats by
but the fact you had a plan you're like
oh no i get to put this here this year
and it
and it just fast-forwards the whole
timeline how much were you making what
was your your salary over this time so i
started making 17
000 roughly and then i did get a
promotion during that time also and i
made up to 32
000 and actually two months after i paid
off all my debt i got another promotion
amazing courtney that's so great so you
did this all on your own because
obviously you just guys just
got married yeah a few days ago it's
just wild um
oklahoma city is that where the wedding
and everything was um it was more closer
to tulsa okay okay
that's where she's from okay and so
david for the last
year or two you've been the second david
in her life
right yes uh oh number two to dave right
you're a financial guy you've been
saying all this stuff
yeah and then this other dave shows up
and
speaking into her other ear tell us tell
us how you've walked alongside her
during this
so we've been each other's
accountability partners so while she was
walking through i was walking through it
myself as well
so we both ended up debt-free i have a
little bit bigger shovel so
uh while she was working through her
baby step number two i was working
through
three and number and number four and so
right now when she got married we're now
on uh four five and six oh wow
amazing you guys that is so exciting
what a way to start off a marriage too
so for you what was the because you were
planning a wedding
while getting out of debt so what was
the hardest part of this past year for
you
i think the hardest part was um really
trusting my future and now spouse
to save for the things that i thought
were going to be important when he
understood
that all right i'm gonna have to put
more money towards the wedding because
she can't right now so it was like i
that was the most stressful part was i
only had two to three months of saving
to pay for the wedding most of it was he
was doing by himself
so it was a lot of trust there yeah and
our parents were very generous
yeah and like we got to save and uh we
actually got
paying for our honeymoon on cash yeah
cash flowed the entire thing
amazing so a year ago as you started
this what changed in your heart i know
you said you took financial peace
university a few things clicked but like
what was the bottom line of like okay i
can hear things that it can sound great
but to actually
do it is a different level of commitment
so
it's a bigger thing to hold the whole
solution is um
eventually i want to be a stay-at-home
mom and that's something that
we were really thinking and talking
about is like i want to stay at home but
i can't do that with 13 000
of debt yeah and having one income so
um this was the this was the biggest
deciding thing is like
i want to have kids and i want to be
able to raise them up and i want to be
able to teach them the teachings that we
are brought up on and um we don't have
beautiful yeah
one day we will and we're gonna be able
to do it in a way that's not a burden to
either one of us so
so huge having that why people in this
journey is
is like one of the most important things
and that's a that's a very honorable why
i love that
so when people listen to debt free
screams or watch them
i know they often think oh my gosh i
don't make 170 thousand dollars
you made 17 000 for this journey and you
topped out at a whopping 32 right
what would you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is because you made
it happen
yeah in a heart with a heart salary it
is not a math problem
you know that's what dave says in the
financial piece it's not it's it's a
i'm going to do this and i'm going to
figure out a way how
and it does it happens and um i don't i
don't know who or where i heard this
from but
it's like you've been trying to do so
much with 100 of your income
but then like when you give god 10
percent like he can do so much with 10
and you can that you could have done
with a hundred like it he just makes a
way
that if you're being diligent and you're
just doing what you're supposed to do
one foot in front of the other
it happens i don't i can't explain it i
don't have but it just does
who are your biggest cheerleaders um
definitely my my now husband
way to go man yes and uh i think uh
khalees matt
and she's one that got us into a
financial piece
as a couple yeah as a couple because our
church offered it
after i just finished and she is
not just only on fire for the lord but
on fire for like just being
compassionate towards people and you
know giving them away like
preaching the message of hope so she was
a huge cheerleader and so
i hope she's going to be watching this
later and so as a young couple
um talking to couples who have been
doing this for a long time or who are
thinking about getting married or have a
wedding coming up
tell them what it's like to be cashflow
in your honeymoon
and you're going to land back and at
home completely debt-free starting this
new adventure together
it's it's gonna it's like really when i
got here it was like oh my gosh
this is what we've been working for this
is this is this is the dream we're doing
it
um it was really stressful and really
hard and there was a lot of times where
i did want to quit
and i would just kind of log on to
the website hear some other people give
some
words of encouragement like it's worth
it at the end it's
definitely worth it um do you have
anything to add
uh no it was just awesome like you know
to do whatever we want
and how we wanted it and just and not
have to worry about
having a bill to pay at the end of it
yeah absolutely okay so we've talked
about how it's not just math right
you've said that a couple of times in
school which is
so true so quickly give me like one or
two
adjectives of emotions of how you felt
in debt
and then how you feel right now standing
on the stage because again it's not just
the math the math that works in your
favor now
yeah because you don't have debt but
there's an emotional change too
um i would say like being in debt it was
always trying to think of like the next
thing
like always feeling behind feeling
behind you can't get caught up and then
on being on the other side of it like
we we have the chance we have a chance
now like we have a hope
and it's we can do things that we've
only ever talked about
yeah yes i love that all right so this
is the big moment we got
david and courtney mostly courtney but
david joined here at the end
from oklahoma city paid off 13 075
in 11 months doing their debt-free
scream
count it down three three two one
we're dead
[Applause]
a newlywed couple cash flowed the
wedding cash flow on the honeymoon
which people say is impossible it's not
real it can't be done right no way
there's no way
man and and starting off marriage
on the same page what a gift and
starting off their debt-free journey
making 17
dollars that's the one i can't wrap my
head around right i would have lost i
wouldn't even have tried i know right
right right takes a lot of courage to
say i don't care where
what my starting line is i'm just gonna
start chipping away at this thing she
killed it she paid off 13 000. i know
she got bumped up to 32 in the middle of
it but
i mean that's it's amazing and a half
hard to believe you're amazing i have to
believe
that when you start getting intentional
however small it is 17 grand
your boss notices your intentionality
your spouse your boyfriend girlfriend
notices your intentionality your friends
your community
and then suddenly you become somebody
that they want to do business with they
want to work with they want to be in a
relationship with because it's just
intentionality breeds attention out
good for you good for you david courtney
debt free
paying it off rock stars this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
joined with best-selling author rachel
cruz taking your calls on life and money
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to joseph in
hattiesburg
joseph what is going on
well i am in a bind um i'm 20 years old
i own uh two businesses as well as the
ebay business
um one's a startup which is not going to
stand be open here soon
but the big one is my vending business
um i'm 179 thousand dollars and
that's down from a quarter million um
this time last year
um my question to you um is since i'm
barely making it throughout i mean
there's bills i have not been able to
pay
this year and parts of last year um
i have a cd as well as an ira account
worth between the two 142 thousand
dollars
it would it be smart for me to cash out
that cd
sell my stock um pay off the
big owner finance loan which is 107 000
um save that 20 000 in interest
and be able to manage those payments
better at that time after selling
okay joseph a couple questions um
you said you have 142 000
in cds and an ira correct
79 in the ira okay
and then your what tell me the rest of
your debt that you have even
personal debt so car loans credit cards
student loans
sure well um i have a full ride to
college so i don't have any student
loans thank the lord
um but i have 107 000 and owner finance
in the vending business i owe the bank
through
other business loans 63 000
and then i have nine thousand dollars
and minor debt
lawyers um cpa a couple other things
okay whoa joseph so what made you get in
you're 20 years old you said right
yes ma'am yeah so you're um
you saw all the opportunity and you just
ran off the other side
to get into get into almost 200 000 of
business debt
well um i've i've owned i actually
bought my first business
um when i was 16 it was a little gumball
business bought for eight thousand
uh brought in like a thousand dollars
every three months it was just a
starting point
and then right before the pandemic in
2019 in october
i um saw a business for sale for
um over a quarter million dollars and i
think um it was
two thousand two hundred thousand um
five hundred
i cannot talk i'm still sorry no you're
fine you're fine um well
250 000 um well
and i i jumped on the opportunity i was
able to get
him to um owner finance which is the
only reason i was able to
get it um of course i don't have really
a lot of credit at this time
okay okay um but i've always
loved doing things like this yeah
absolutely okay so what
what income are you making currently
i'm putting everything into it um well i
have a personal drive on top of this
business
um i'm bringing in about 50 000 a year
um
right under 50 000 yes 50. that mainly
goes per
personal expenses of living rent etc
but what do you make what do you make
total a year what how much will you make
this year
50 or more um
slightly less than 50. slightly less
than 50. okay and is that that's gross
huh so my guess is
you're a smooth talker and so you're
gonna make 50 grand but you're going to
take home
half that roughly yes sir
okay so joseph what i would do if i were
you i would not touch the ira because
you're going to pay
taxes on that when you cash it out early
um
because you're not retirement age so i
would i wouldn't touch that i would cash
out everything else the cdf cash out
today of 64 000
any other money you have i would cash
out i would
leave a thousand dollars for an
emergency fund and i would throw
everything else
at this debt and the beautiful thing is
the two the nine thousand and the
sixty-three i know you only have
sixty-four but you
you could probably get these two paid
off fair fairly quickly considering you
have 64 000 in that cd and then that
hundred and seven thousand i mean
that's equivalent to people's student
loans right i'm like people that's
that's a student loan we hear on the
show a lot so
with your income you're a hustler which
i love like you
you work hard you find the way to make
deals like you can make
things happen and so i want you to be
able to do that with your income i want
you to expand your income i want you to
work like
crazy because you're not in school
correct i want to make sure i got that
i am in school i'm a full-time student
15 hours are in school okay i'm so sorry
i missed that yep
um so for you and you have a scholarship
so
i would say i mean yeah i would
how much longer do you have to graduate
i have two years
two more years okay then i'm sorry i'm
gonna change my answer joseph i think i
would pause on this
and i would get through school i think
your priority right now is to get
through debt-free even though you have a
scholarship and all of that but just in
case life happens that you're not
accruing more debt
getting out of school um and then the
bills that you can't
pay right now you could cash out that cd
and put money towards that to at least
get caught up so you're not behind
and then once you graduate i would go
aggressive on all of this then and that
way you have you're not
spending time in school you can go get
make more money because you have more
time
all of that so so again i'll i'll say it
i would i would pause i would get
through school
i would cash out some of that cd to stay
current
on your debts and then i would just go
nuts after graduation and just start
paying all this off
and hey joseph absolutely joseph yeah
you're you are a hustler right yes sir
okay and you
got out hustled here because you played
with the big kids
right with bankers and with private
loans
and you saw opportunities and
you got hit in the mouth this has to be
your moment
where you say i will never ever ever
borrow money again
you are too smart you're clearly smart
you got a full ride to college
you're too smart and you're too driven
and you've got too much to add to this
world
to spend that energy that you could be
contributing to the
communities that my kids are going to
grow up in you got too much to offer to
spend that time shoveling
crap from mistakes that you made in the
past
does that make sense absolutely yes sir
so here's the deal joseph i need you
i need your mind to need your hustle i
need your solution-oriented brain to not
borrow any more money ever again
i'm with you i totally agree got it good
if you can learn that lesson as a 20
year old
you've won life right you've won you've
won
if you roll it over and you need to
learn it again
in when you're 24 and you're 32
and then you're 38. and i'll tell you
rachel
for somebody like joseph that's a drug
the next deal is a drug and this thing's
gonna it's gonna
haunt him for a season unless he goes
scorched earth
like dave did no matter
what never again no it's a great point
because again it's that
that itch that you're going to scratch
yourself it's in your personality you're
like i'm like
put numbers on the sheet of paper i'm
like this is like not even 30 year olds
have this situation right like you're 20
so
obviously your brain is just going and
you're talented and you're smart and all
that but putting that energy just like
you said
towards something good i'm like you
could become wealthy so
quickly with the amount of work ethic
and the way your brain thinks
oh if you just don't mess with it don't
don't mess with it and you can
you can [ __ ] your family tree yeah if
you go the other direction
right it it reminds me of somebody who's
like
people who go to vegas at once a year or
once every five years and they like to
play blackjack a little bit and they
take 100
and play blackjack they don't and that's
most people
they don't have a frame of reference for
somebody who is a gambling addict
who will be walking into a building and
see somebody
and say hey i bet you that you know i
bet i could feel this rock farther
it becomes part of you and this is a guy
looking at craigslist for deals looking
at
you know listening to conversations in a
coffee shop looking for deals
this is in his soul man and someone's
always gonna be willing to loan him
money
and he's just gonna have to wrestle with
it hey i wanna go back rachel really
quick before the
the break well you know what we're done
with the break we have to wait till the
next hour
they got lucky good folks james is like
i can't wait
i know he can't wait hey thank you so
much rachel we got one hour in the books
here
and we'll be back soon right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsey show
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your money and your life i'm john
dolone joined here by my good friend
best-selling author awesome mom and
friend rachel cruz
and we are taking your calls on anything
and everything money
life however we can help give us a shout
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to victoria
in orlando victoria what's going
hi on hi rachel it's such a pleasure to
speak with you thank you so much for
taking my call
you bet how can we help so
um so i'm getting finances in order and
planning out i've arranged my active
deaths in the debt snowball
and have been chipping away at that um
so in a matter of months i should be
completing my debt snowball amazing now
i'm trying to
oh thank you all thanks to to you guys
thanks
um so what i'm trying to do now is plan
um for two deaths that i have uh that
are currently in collection since
2019 and um and they've been
bought by a few companies between then
and now
um one is worth about 1400 and the other
is worth about
um 1 000. so i'm trying to plan to see
for when i'm ready to tackle those what
is a good
um percentage of it to offer since i
know that they buy it for pennies on the
dollar
that is not too much on my wallet but
also
enough leverage to pay it off but also
negotiate for them to get it off my
credit reports
okay how much other debt do you have
you said you'll be using the other debt
um so with the debt snowball um the
credit card debt i have
is um uh let's say 2001
and then 1000 on the other um so
in a in a couple of months i should be
able to knock that out
okay and how much do you make a year
um i make i recently got a new job
um so a salary a year it's about
thirty thousand okay
and the one and the debt that are in
collections the two debts what kind of
debts are though
are they um the one for a thousand four
hundred
is with um uh it's with a cell phone
company t-mobile
um i lost my job at that time so um
i fell behind on payments and they
brought it to collections
and then the one that's worth a thousand
is uh
from an apartment um where
um i wasn't able to pay the post move
out costs
right away and so that went to
collections okay gotcha
yeah so when you're when you're dealing
with this stuff i mean like you said
these companies are bought constantly
right they buy each other
and they're passed to one person to the
other and it says guys and cubicles with
headsets basically calling
and you know collecting this debt so so
the truth is yeah you can do
pennies on the dollar um i mean i i
would say
to find an amount for you because they
are so
they're such ankle biters like it's
fourteen hundred dollars it's a thousand
dollars like it's these
smaller amounts right we're not talking
about 20 grand or something
right so there's a level that you know
you owe
this money this is debt and now that
you're in a stable position
you can still negotiate for sure um
but it's enough to say yeah i feel good
to offer this amount so
whether it's i don't know
300 bucks 400 bucks and see what they
they give you um you can always just
throw out the numbers right and talk
about it so there's like this
this balance in my head of yeah
negotiate
get it less get it in writing once they
agree upon it all of that
and then from there though the fact that
you have a stable income and you owe
those debts
there's a level that i'm like man would
it feel good just to pay the debt like
you owe the debt
you have the money uh you're working it
putting into that snowball and just
getting it out and just
um paying what you owe as well do you
know what i mean like if you were on the
brink
if you didn't have a job um if you had
multiple debts and collections
big amounts of debt i mean all of this
the whole idea of negotiating
and all of that i'm like yes to get you
out of this hole but you're working a
plan victoria you have control for the
first time
in a long time it sounds like from just
the tone of your voice and you're going
to be completely
free so soon so there's a part of me
victoria
there's a little bit of dignity to say
hey i owe this
and i can pay it this thousand dollars
like i can pay it you can negotiate
if that's what you choose to do and
they'll probably take a lower amount to
settle
um but there's something in me i don't
know victoria just of paying off what
you owe
you know that that's that's how i take
on it rachel and i i love
i love negotiating and haggling um our
friend anthony used to be a debt
collector and he said call at the end of
the month because they're trying to
close out their books
and you can say hey i'll give you this
you send me an in-writing agreement
right now we'll get this paid
and yeah right 300 400 and there's the
other side
that who cares how many times it's been
sold
you owe that dollar amount and i'll
always like to go back to the dignity
paying the debt is my responsibility
right i'm gonna make this payment
and there's something about that that
standing tall i i
owe this money i'm gonna pay i don't
care who i'm paying it too that's not
the point the point is
i'm gonna pay what i owe yeah yeah so
victoria i don't think it's i don't
think it's a
bad call if you decide to negotiate get
a lower amount do it um
but also i think thinking through just
for yourself and your unconscious and
your story of that
um there's just power there's power in
that um i'm gonna i'm gonna
say this because i don't know if i can
about it i don't know
dad's story of bankruptcy he went back
years later
okay this goes back yeah and there's
something about that and again i don't
think he publicly talks about that very
often but there's some there's
okay i was like i don't think it's a
secret uh but he did because i mean he
haunted it he didn't know it but there's
that there's that i don't know that
piece of the morality of
man i i said i would pay this money back
and again
legally you don't have to you know all
of that but there's there's something to
the soul of money this emotional side of
money
that is very real and there's a freedom
to know i gave my word to someone
and i'm going to complete that yeah even
if it's years later
i'm with you and student loans was
me and my wife we ended up with six
figures of student loans a lot right we
had a whole bunch of degrees a whole
bunch of
debt and i love the idea of of
the the philosophy of you know it'd be
cool if the government came in and wiped
them all away from me
and i honestly it's 17 18 19 i didn't
know what i was signing i know right
but i also came back to man i put my
name on a piece of paper
that said if you'll help me get through
college whoever you are i'll pay you
back
and there was a grind and it was awful
and we had to do all this
but man i get to help hold my head up
high so we figured it out how to do it
and it was
miserable and i also know there's
systems that trap
i get all that but there's something
about i love that part of dave's story
that he quietly went by behind closed
doors no fanfare
and said hey i owe you this money and
i'm going to pay you um there's
something
yeah there's something remarkable about
that speaking of are you tired of
feeling stuck
with your money like you'll never get
out of debt or save for the future
listen
it doesn't have to be that way go to
ramsey plus get a ramsey plus membership
you'll get access to the premium version
of their every dollar app it's the one
me and rachel
use in our personal lives plan out every
dollar connect your budget to your bank
so you never miss a transaction get
custom budget reports
you can do it all starting today
and you're going to make progress fast
for a free trial of ramsay plus
text trial to 33789 that's
trial to 33789 we're not just trying to
sell you something this is the stuff
that
rachel and myself we all use this trial
to 33789 start making progress
today we'll be right back on the ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out
[Music]
more
[Music]
so
this is the ramsey show glad you're with
us i'm john dolone joined here with
rachel cruz and we're taking your calls
on life and money triple eight eight two
five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to kelly in
buffalo new york
kelly what's going on hi how are you
good how are you i'm good i'm just
um wanting to ask you about the car that
i'm trying to get so i'm in
college right now you know i'm going to
be finished come the end of summer
because i'm doing an accelerated program
very cool and for my job i need to get a
car
because i'm doing a lot of um like
transporting stuff i'll be driving other
people around
and i need to get one soon i have about
ten thousand dollars saved up
because i've been school paid off and
i'm just i don't want to put all my
money into a car
because then my insurance would be
higher and stuff so i'm just wondering
like what do i
like should i put half of it into
financing a new car with low interest
or do i put all of it into a new one or
do i get like a
a lower quality just use one with really
high kilometers i just really don't know
what to do
yeah it's a great question kelly um when
we look at cars
i will tell you um from the financial
standpoint
when people lease cars or they take
out a loan on a car
it's it's the hardest justification for
me mathematically to go there so
i'll give you an example student loans
for anti-student loans here we're all
about paying your way through school
but people can make the argument yes but
i am getting this
loan because i'm going to make x amount
of salary and it's going to come back
right or a mortgage is the one type of
debt we don't yell at you for because
real estate will go up in value and it's
a large purchase like
um the so the way i look at car debt
specifically it's the hardest
it's the hardest one for me to logically
understand because you're taking
the loan outs and paying interest on
something that's going
down in value when there are so
many options out there that can be
different
aka like you said your third option was
buying a used car with cash
and i would do that day in and day out
car debts for me is is the hardest debt
to hear about because i think oh my god
you're buying something that's going
down in value but
yet you're going to be paying more for
it on the back end so
if i were you kelly if i woke up in your
shoes
i would take that 10 grand and
i i would go and and kelly blue book or
um
or craigslist look i mean there there
are used cars everywhere
and you can get a great used car for for
seven grand
and you'd have three thousand left over
a paid for car it's not going to be
fancy it's not going to be
beautiful probably but you can get a
standard great
used car we will have high mileage for
five
seven thousand dollars easily kelly
easily so
i would do that in a heartbeat and again
we're not against nice cars here on the
show
i want you to get a great car i i think
that that's awesome
um but i want you to pay for it and in
your stage of life right now
um i think that that kind of car to
transport back and forth would be
totally sufficient and a very smart move
financially
and kelly i'll tell you this i'm
surrounded by car people
rachel's a car person dave for sure
anthony yes i just love teslas
rachel's a car person i don't have a
tesla um the car is in my house
my wife drives a 2010 and i drive an 06
and when my kid i've told the story on
this show but when hank crawled into the
2006 truck because it was an upgrade
from the 98 i was driving
he got in it and he looked around for a
second he looked at me and said
dad are we rich i was like yes we are
right
so all i have to say is you can find a
great used car
in college for 5 000 bucks and
you can buy some sort of honda or toyota
and drive it until the wheels
you're going to get frustrated because
it's going to keep going and keep going
and keep going
and it's that's absolutely keep some
money in the bank and but
do not lease a car there all right let's
go to jenny in charlotte jenny what's
going on
oh hi rachel and dr john how are you
guys doing
good good good how are you
great hey i have a quick question for
both of you since you are
book writers um my mother who was the
most
influential amazing talented unique
woman i've ever met
passed away about two years ago and i
have this
dream to do a series of children's books
about her life you know obviously
inspired
you know from how she raised me and
i just wanted to get um your opinion
from both of you
um do i go with a vanity press do i do
amazon how do i contact an illustrator
like what
i don't i literally don't even know
where to start with all this uh what
goes into writing a book or yeah
i would love your opinion yes that's so
fun i i've had more conversations jenny
you're honestly like the fifth person
i've talked to
about writing books like in the last two
weeks what a cool way to honor your mom
i know i love that yeah so i think in
today's world it's
it's probably it's the easiest time to
write a book i mean
20 years ago you kind of had to do the
traditional publishers route and you
know i mean like it was it was kind of
harder to
have contacts and get stuff made and
printed and all of that but now
i'm like man there there's just options
everywhere
so i mean in charlotte i'm sure there's
a local artist
somewhere that does drawings um multiple
of them that you could you can
research and look google go on instagram
i mean like look around in your
area or even doesn't have to be in
charlotte and find someone that you love
their style and contact them you know
you'll
you'll pay for them to do the
illustrations after you've written the
manuscript
um and my wife is actually shopping
children's books right now there you go
and so here's her story um she's
deciding between she's holding an offer
right now
and she's also in where you are jenny's
saying should we just publish this
ourselves and i think it comes back to
what you want to do with it
do you want to do a small project that
honors your mom and hand this book out
to family and friends and maybe sell it
to a few people
of course you want to become the next
shel silverstein and make a million
dollars but
do you want to do you want to do this
and pass it out and in that case yeah
you
just self-publish it and get a great
cool local author
what do you want to do jenny with it
what would be your dreams for the series
well i know i'm biased but my mother was
literally
like the best woman i've ever known and
i feel like a lot of people could
benefit from
all the things that she's taught me and
how she raised us and
to make it like parent-friendly but also
that a parent can read it to kids and i
think it could
really explode again i'm biased sure
sure so it could be more than just like
a family pass out okay yeah so what's
she like so
when you take a a more traditional
publisher route you go to a conference
you meet with agents
um and there's a whole process for
tracking down agents
and sending um there's actually a manual
that you can get out to track the agents
down and you email them
you make a pitch for your book if you go
through a traditional publisher
publishing house they actually provide
you with the
illustrator they tell you what the cover
is going to look like what the
illustrator is going to look like and so
you give up a lot of control for the
opportunity to have your book in walmart
and barnes and noble and whatnot
and so i would recommend getting in
contact with
either literary agencies getting in
contact with
individual agents and you can now with
the internet you can just track them
down
and you can find out who's publishing
children's books who's asking for
children's books
and then you can get online and learn
how to do a traditional pitch letter um
and have your manuscript and be ready to
go that way look at you john
i learned all kinds of stuff about this
so sheila's doing a book
yeah yeah well she's she's she's working
through all kinds of yeah she's a way
better writer than i am it's kind of
embarrassing
that this is what i do for a living
she's so much better at it than me um
but yeah i've learned a lot about how
the process works and again it goes back
my wife's very similar and the impetus
for this was how do we honor family
right and how do you how do you tell
a beautiful story about folks who meant
something to you which i think is a cool
way to do that it's beautiful
when you sit down to write a book rachel
you've and you've written multiple
bestsellers do you have something like a
burning message that you that you want
to get out they think hey
this is this is i gotta i gotta tell
somebody this
or do you have some ideas that you want
to wrap your head around is that how you
think
how do you sit down to write a book i
mean my three
came out of experiences that i had had
okay so i feel like i kind of
experienced it before i wrote the book
and and it came out of struggle like the
things that i'm like oh the aha moments
in life and the things
like oh gosh i've been struggling with
this so i'm sure like love your life not
theirs all about comparison
right i went through a whole season of
that and at the end of it i was like oh
this
affects my money so much and i want to
write about it because i know people are
struggling with it so so
it's that's meeting it's meeting the
need as well that's a gift so
you should sit down and write a book to
say hey i've walked this journey
i've still got skin knees from this one
[Music]
yeah i don't have to do this right you
have to go through this hopefully you're
so much more
kinder than i am no
i sit down to write a book and i gotta
process it man oh my gosh
it's me working it out in my head you're
a much better person this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm john
dolone joined here with best-selling
author rachel cruz taking your calls on
money and life triple eight eight two
five five
two two five let's go to nick out in
cincinnati ohio nick what's going on man
hi how are you can you hear me yeah we
can hear you great how's it going
i'm good how are you very cool very good
i am 17 years old
and a junior in high school and i am
getting prepared to
start looking for colleges and i'm just
trying to navigate the best way
to figure out how i can pay for it while
also setting myself up
in the future for financial success
yeah that's a great ques question nick i
feel like
it's one that every high school student
basically
has to filter through what am i gonna do
after graduation and choosing
if college is is the next step and so um
what do you what do you wanna do do you
have a do you have a passion right now
for what you wanna major in or where you
wanna go to school kind of what what are
you thinking
um i would like to be in something that
involves computer science i've always
had a love for technology ever since i
was young
and i definitely like to expand into
that as a
potential career that's a good career
right now
yeah people are gonna
you will get a job nick i can say that
much um
that's awesome are your parents and are
they involved at all
on any level of the discussion or
financially
yeah so i have three other siblings as
well um
two of them have gone to college and my
parents are
definitely supportive of whatever
decision i want to go through
they are also helping me out they set
aside money for me
as well they've taught me principles on
saving money and all that
and they've really helped me out and are
helping me to come
to a decision but now the biggest
question is
how is it going to be paid for and i'm
just trying to do this in
like pretty much the path of least
resistance yeah for sure
well hold on i would say the path of
least resistance is to go sign up for a
student loan and worry about it in five
years
don't do that right right yeah i mean
passive lease resistance still
to get me to financial financial success
as close as i can so go to college
definitely
yes right there you go trying to figure
out how to do that yep so
um i mean a couple of things nick
they're um
i think the the starting point is
figuring out okay you said your parents
are willing to help you some but to get
a dollar amount and to have a very clear
communication with okay how much
are they able to help me in this and
then from there you can kind of look to
see okay how much
money will i have can i think that i
estimate if i work
all of this how much i think i can cash
flow
um and school choice right is gonna be
the biggest decision you make on a
financial
side so you can for instance go to a
private school
pay upwards of i don't know john what
you just picked a number
56 11 million dollars no like per
semester
whatever you yeah i mean at the wall zoo
the private school you could go
there's some private schools that are
really reasonably priced right but it
goes back to that money probably yes
question right um you could step over a
state line
and go you're in ohio uh go to
indiana and triple your costs probably
pay three times as much
to go to that public school versus
staying in
ohio uh you go to a community college
which will be
probably your least uh expensive
routes um for a traditional college
degree
uh do that for a few years all right so
there's all there's a gamut
of the the most expensive to the least
or if you know you want to do computer
science you can go
to a local community college for nine
months and get a certificate yes and get
into the workforce
and then go to school on the side go to
school in the evenings go to school
two or three days a week and work
towards your degree while you're earning
money along the way too
and get you know going to school for
coding i mean there's all these other
yeah
these these paths on that other side as
well so so i mean the biggest decision
nick honestly
it's going to come down to school choice
i mean you can cash flow your way
um through a community college through
going you know even at night or
something just like you said you could
even cashflow your way through a state
school
you could do that but i would say for
the roi
of what you put into your degree um has
to match with what you're going to get
paid and the problem is nick is that
people just go to whatever school they
want to go to they pay
an insane amount of money when they
could have had the exact same outcome
and paid less for that degree because of
school choice so
my biggest push to you is going to be
school choice so
community college and state tuition and
then on top of that i mean scholarships
and grants
free money i mean you can go there and
then working as well
so all of that combined there is a way
nick i promise there's a way to go to
school debt-free
but what you said at the beginning yeah
the path of least resistance i know you
didn't necessarily mean that
because it's gonna be hard and it is
it's it's
it's sacrificing and putting intensity
and work and energy
for four years of your life so it's not
gonna be fun like it's not fun nick like
you're like oh my gosh i want to be
doing all this other stuff or maybe i
have this dream to go to this other
school but i'm choosing not to
but you're doing that hard work from you
know 18 to 21
so that the rest of your life you don't
have student loan debts and you get to
do what you want you have options and
choices
so there's a beauty in making the
sacrifice early even though it's not fun
at the moment
um versus having to pay for it into
into adulthood and for students and
parents out there for whatever it's
worth
um my mom she's in her 70s
she's got a phd she's an english
professor
she worked as a english professor now
worked as a controller in big accounting
firms
um started a community college i've got
a bunch of degrees my wife's
a pick out a phd and we're all in
different things and if my son came and
said hey i'm 17 and i really want to get
into computers
i would high five him on the way to a
local community college if that's what
he wanted to do
i would have it would be an
extraordinary place to start i know
those professors i know
community college presidents they're
they are setting kids up to be
successful
and i'm a guy that's worked at multiple
private schools right yeah
if we had the money and he comes that's
what i want to do i'd high five them
there too
but there's a stigma around certificate
programs there's a stigma around
community colleges and i think they're
an extraordinary
choice if that's what you want to do and
if they've got a program for you locally
you can maybe even live at home for a
few years nick and transfer out and
knock off half the price so as rachel
said
really get to where you want to go and
reverse engineer it we had a debt-free
scream
in a previous hour that i she said
something that was really powerful
rachel she said
i had this goal to be a stay-at-home mom
and i looked at my current situation and
said i couldn't just do that today
and so she went one two three however
many years out
and just worked it back and said that
means i got to start living differently
right this second
and i think that level of intentionality
is something that's absent from our
world today
right and so all it's the opposite
what's going to be the thing that it
feels the best
right this second and then i'm going to
deal with whatever happens on the back
end
and man with just some hard
intentionality up front
you can really just shift your entire
life another direction and nick i mean
like you're such a great place the fact
that
you know how many calls we get on the
other side of the story right with all
the student loan debts and
those questions i mean you are in a
perfect position nick to make
a decision that literally can change you
financially for the rest of your life
versus paying student loans back
investing
investing that money i mean like like
it's just it's crazy to think
what all you can do right now with just
a decision to say okay
it's gonna look different it's not gonna
be what everyone else is doing
but so worth it so nick i want you to
hang on the line we're gonna give you a
copy of our buddy anthony o'neill's
best-selling book debt-free degree
and while we're talking about books
listen our famous
ten dollar sale is here at ramsey
solutions
now you can learn how to make faster and
real progress with your money when you
check out our famous
ten dollar sale save up to sixty percent
on over 40 best-selling books and
budgeting tools like debt-free degree
the total money makeover
my book redefining anxiety rachel's got
like 38 best-selling books on this
list um know yourself know your money's
most recent um
best-selling book that has taken the
world over by storm
shop our 10 sales at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
and that's not all we've got a gift for
you you can also enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway we're giving up
away 500 cash every week in a grand
prize of 5
000 cash enter daily for extra chances
to win
text cash to three three seven eight
nine
that's cash to three three seven eight
nine ten bucks
ten bucks get online ramsay
solutions.com buy some books ten dollars
change your life we'll be right back
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
do
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
let's go out to bowen in phoenix arizona
bowen what's going on
hi there i am 23 years old
and i'm in college right now i'm
going to trade school for diesel
and uh my school tuition is about
four thousand dollars um i'm getting
assistance
from my parents through uh the va
and that's about ten thousand dollars
total
or about twelve thousand dollars total
um i'm currently
working and making about 41 000
this year and
i have some debt and
i'm going to have my student loans too
and i'm just trying to figure out if i
should be paying off the debt
first or if i should be paying off the
student loans
because um i did have to get a parent
plus loan
and so um it would be paying off my
parents
loan and not through the school
so i'm just trying to figure out if i
should pay off the uh
school or if i should pay off my debt or
because it's
all my debt center collection yep um
okay so
how much longer of school how much how
much longer until you graduate
well it's a trade school so it's only a
year-long program and i've been in
since december so i got about six more
months six more months okay and how are
you paying you took out loans to go to
this trade school
what is it what was that did you take
out a loan to go to this year of school
yeah yes you did okay hey you're making
forty one thousand 000
what are you in collections over you're
making a good salary how are you behind
on your debts
um so i just recently was uh
released back in the society i was in
prison for two years okay and
um so all that debt was
acquired from making pretty bad life
choices
and uh you know starting big counts and
over withdrawing and stuff like that
and you know things like that and uh
so you're grinding it out cleaning up a
mess you turn the page
you're pretty you're exactly yeah you're
a brave guy getting back into it huh
yeah hey i'm proud of you brother i've
been oh thank you
so i've been out since november okay and
uh
so i've just been working since then and
i'm
just trying to figure out what i should
be doing because you know that stuff
kind of really stuff's gonna do
yep yeah it makes me upset thinking
about it all the time and then but
then on the other hand i have my school
and there's no
interest for the first six months uh
after i graduate as well so how'd you
get connected with us bowen
um my grandma she actually watches your
show
era listens to it and then um everybody
on my work this is
the radio station in all the cars so
okay it's awesome
well bow and yeah you're all like what
john said you you have an extraordinary
story i mean the fact that you've
had the past and you've come out and
you're going to school now
and you're you're changing up your life
i think it's i think it's remarkable and
i think
um i think you're going to kill it
financially i think you can do this
bowen i mean you're making a great
salary right now
so um another question for you the
debts that are in collections what are
those debts and how much
so i have um two emergency room visits
so
those two put together is like three
thousand dollars and then i have
a phone debt that's around two thousand
dollars from verizon
and then i have um some
bank accounts where i had the overdraft
on it
and so i was withdrawing money or
whatever
and um so there's about
another four thousand dollars total for
all of that
as well okay and then
your student loan is what's left correct
yeah so my parents uh their loan
was for nine thousand dollars and then
my loan for the rest
and then i did get a pell grant
and that was like the three okay so nine
and three so that's 12 and then my loans
all together like 11.
yep i got you okay that's awesome well
um i would say where you're at i would
with the income you have i would love
for you to pay off what's in collections
i think that that's going to be a weight
lifted off your shoulders and you have
the
income coming in i mean the 41 thousand
dollars what we teach
bowen is paying off the smallest debt
to the largest regardless of the
interest rate
and paying minimum payments on
everything and attacking that smallest
debt first
so as quickly as you can get current on
the debts that are in collections i
would do that first and foremost
making a plan of that um since you have
the income we had a call just like this
a few segments ago bowen about um the
fact that
the debts that are in collections you
can negotiate for pennies on the dollar
and
you know be able to reduce this amount
that's in collections you can choose
that
or you may say you know what i have the
income coming in and i want to just pay
off the debt i know this two
there's two thousand dollars here that
three thousand here four thousand here
i wanna pay it off um but i would i
would get
current with where you can and then
start working on those smaller debts
that are in collections
and then once you graduate in december
start knocking out that 11 grand in
student loans
and bo and i mean i'll be honest with
the numbers you're giving us and that
we're seeing like
you i mean your life financially can
look
so different a year from now like you
can look up
you know february march of of 2022 and
you will be debt free you if you stick
with this and you do this
you could have no debt you're starting a
completely clean slate financially
but also emotionally and with and with
your life i think it's just amazing
so bowen if if we help you out
are you committed to going all in
oh yeah that's i mean that's the plan
i'm
just you know i'm also trying to figure
out how to do you know
investments and start uh different
accounts and stuff like that
because that's all my grandma keeps
telling me and then
but that's you know here's here's what
we're gonna do about all the big
here's what we're gonna do um
you've had a hard row and you got out of
jail and you are
doing your best to turn it around and
you put your nose to the grindstone you
started working you're making a good
salary and then on top of that you're
going back to school
and now what you need is you need some
people in your corner that are going to
um
match your hard work and are going to
support you so here's what i'm going to
do
rachel and i are going to send you a
copy of the total money makeover for
free
it's dave's book and sold millions of
copies and it has got people out of debt
but i'm only going to send it to you if
you commit to reading it start to finish
okay and it will walk you through an
investment strategy it'll walk you
through how to live
and hold on i'm also going to give you a
year's subscription to our premium
product ramsey plus
it's got the an app that will link with
your bank account so no more overdrafts
it's going to teach you how to do it
right it's going to
it's going to keep up with you that kind
of budget it's going to
have all the lessons of financial peace
university that you can watch and i want
you to watch it with your grandmother
because you're not only getting your
money right you're getting relationships
right too
right and with your parents too let's
get everybody in the loop on this deal
and this is what's going to have you can
have coaching calls on this thing
it's going to be a tool it's going to be
a one-stop shop from you for the next
year as you finish cleaning up this mess
and as rachel i love to clean slate
relationally with the people who love
you
the clean slate financially and then
brother you're gonna have a credential
you're gonna have some new skills you
clearly have work ethic you've clearly
turned things around and then you're
gonna be off to the races
and then when you get cleared up the
last thing i'm gonna hitch to you
is you're gonna buy a copy with your own
money a total money makeover you're
going to give it to somebody else who
needs it
okay yeah thank you
all right so hey we're backing you and
now all you've got is
a a road of hard work but you have a
direction now where you can go
and i'm proud of you and um we're gonna
walk alongside you i want you to call us
back and keep us informed if you ever
need anything let us know
and um once you know we're in your
corner and rachel
it goes man we hear so
many excuses on this show
so many people call and say hey i'm
making 175 000 and i really
want this new bmw but i don't trade in
my old one and
can we you know what i mean and then you
talk to someone like bowen who's
clearly all right he screwed up
and then he got up and he dusted himself
off and other people helped him pick him
up
and now he's off to make right i love it
bow and i'm excited for you
it's awesome well rachel thank you so
much for joining us
kelly james and happy birthday kelly
happy 21st birthday
we're so excited this is a big one she
can gamble not good folks
another segment in the books thank you
for joining us this has been the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your money
and your life i am john deloney joined
here with best-selling author
and brilliant friend rachel cruz and
we're taking your calls on anything and
everything
on your money your relationships
parenting all of it give us a call at
two 825-5225-825-5225 five we have a
lobby full of people here today it's
good to see everybody
smiling faces even the not so smiling
faces it's good to see everybody
and rachel it's always fun to have you
on the show i'm glad you're here man i
know thanks john always fun
all right let's go out to cincinnati
ohio and talk to
noah no what's going on
hey john and rachel it's a huge honor to
talk to you thanks so much for taking my
call
the honor is all ours what's up man how
can we help
so my wife and i are in baby steps four
five and six
um i'm a registered nurse and i have the
opportunity to
go back to school to become a nurse
practitioner
i'm looking at going full time my wife
and i have
looked at the costs and crunched the
numbers and we're able to cash flow
the cost of school for the next two
years
my question is and a lot of employers
offer tuition reimbursement
um for nurse practitioners along you
know another you know and other jobs but
in order to get tuition reimbursement
you have to have student loans
so i was wondering would it make sense
rather than
paying it off as i go and then cash
flowing it rather to just stockpile a
bunch of cash to
pay off school and if i'm able to get um
tuition reimbursement through my
employer great
they can help me pay off some or all of
it and if not i can just you know
um i can just pay it all off
after i graduate with one stroke of a
pen does that make sense
yes it does make sense um
i would say i would not take out loans
and just yeah write the check at the end
if you have the money no i would pay
your way through but there's also
another option
because companies do reimburse tuition
if there is an employer that you could
get on board with before you start
school
and they could help pay your way through
as you work maybe at a lower level
position in the company until you get
the degree
um or whatever that looks like there's
an option there that i've heard
many people do that they will go and
work for a company and that employer
helps
pay their way through um so that's
that's another
angle to look at what yeah no what's the
benefit is it just time is that why
you're going to go full time
instead of working your way through it
yeah so my plan is to work full-time
and go to school full-time most programs
like this are designed for working
adults so
oh i'm sorry i thought you said you were
gonna quit working and go full
time okay so you're gonna work full-time
and go to school full-time
yeah that's the plan outstanding so does
your current
employer offer a tuition reimbursement
they do but it's like and i need to get
with hr to know the details on it but
it's like a thousand dollars a year or
something that is i mean it's better
than nothing but it doesn't cover
it doesn't really come close to that and
is that the same
employer you want to be with after you
get this degree or will you change
i'm certainly open to staying with my
current employer i like my employer yeah
but i'm not married to that idea
sure so so here's what i would do no i
would not
it's been my experience that a number of
these tuition reimbursement
programs end up being like what you're
experiencing now
it's hey we reimburse tuition it's an
incredible benefit and you get in there
and you sit down and it's a thousand
bucks
a thousand bucks is a thousand bucks and
no one's going to complain about it but
in your head it's like oh sweet you're
going to pay 35
000 of this program the other side of it
is
the ones that i again there may be
different ones the ones i know of
personally
come with strings attached meaning we're
going to pay you back but you're going
to owe us four years
yeah we're gonna you're gonna owe us
three years or if you work this
particular shift then we're gonna pick
it up at this level
here's what i'm gonna tell you in my
head i'm gonna
i've you've worked hard you can cash
flow this thing you're gonna pay it all
the way
through and then you're gonna have no
strings to anybody
at any time for anything and that'd be
my recommendation
what i don't want you to do is to get
all the way through and then you're
gonna start having to look at particular
job options
based on how good this particular
benefit is
rather than how good the particular job
is for your family what your family's
going to look like in two or three years
and so man you that nurse practitioner
degree is going to be gold you're going
to be able to do
and go pretty much wherever you want to
go don't
add in another variable to that equation
which is what's your tuition
reimbursement program and i'd go down to
the current job you've got now
and take their thousand bucks or see if
you can negotiate that up or
man pay this first semester and get on
the market and
start trying to find another job in your
area that's going to have a higher
tuition reimbursement program and i've
seen it the most common way i've seen it
done is or the way
mine worked was i would pay my tuition
and then i would just take a copy of the
bill that i just paid and they would
reimburse that i didn't have to have a
student loan to come in there and do
that yeah so yeah
um lots of options around it that's
that's that's our recommendation man
appreciate the call and good luck to you
man it's gonna be
you're gonna be a busy guy working full
time and going to a doctoral program
full time good for you
all right jessica in houston what's
going on jessica
hi how are you good how are you i'm good
i'm good thank you
so um i was calling because i have
finished
um baby step two and three
my husband and i on baby step four
and uh thank you so much thank you
and um i have a 401k
with a previous company that i was with
that is still there
i am no longer with that company um
and the reason why i didn't originally
move it over because i was silly
and i took money out of my 401k um
but i've paid it all back um
but i wanted to know if i should roll
over my 401k
to the current company that i'm with or
if i should just let it sit
where it is yeah that's a great question
jessica
um i said the first thing i would do is
get with one of our smart vesters
in your area and sit down with them
because
the best option is to not leave it there
and not roll it over to
your new employer i would roll it over
to just a traditional ira
um if you want to pay the taxes you can
roll it into a roth
but just roll it into yeah more of an
independent just traditional ira
and you can do that with one of our
smart fester pros an investment
professional to help you work on all
those details but
that that would be that would be my
suggestion that way if you move it to
your new company
and then two or three years down the
road you get a new job you're not always
rolling these things over you've got a
central account that is yours that you
control that you partner with the smart
wrestler pro on
and then if you leave your company in a
few years you can take what you've
accrued to this company and roll it back
to the account
that you own yeah but it keeps you from
rolling them from company to company
yes and i i hear that that i was dumb i
should have
hey man it took me a long long
long time years to go back and go oh i
still got a 401 at this place and a 403
at this place
and to get it all into one one place
it's a lot it's a
it's a mess and i was ashamed of it and
embarrassed about it and then my smart
investor pro that i work with was like
man
i deal with this every single day
totally oh get over yourself and
stop wine and deloney and let's line
this stuff up and get you
and your family on the road to success
so it's a good deal good for you jessica
i appreciate the call this is the ramsay
show we'll be right back hang with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
firsts
[Music]
so
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
joined here with rachel cruz and we're
taking your calls
at 825-5225
according to the united states census
bureau nearly
1 in 10 people relocated last year
that was in 2020 that means this year
there's a good chance
you or someone you know is planning a
big move rachel we've talked about this
in the hallway yes the real estate
market has lost
its mind now i know it feels like
there's a thousand unknowns you're
juggling when you're relocating should i
buy where should i buy
can we even buy you cannot lose focus of
one of the most important
personal and financial factors in your
move your housing
i recommend hiring a quality real estate
agent like one of our endorsed local
providers or elps
that help you find the right home in
your new city
they're top performing experts not
friends of your friends
brothers grandma's roommate they are top
performing experts in their local market
and have years of experience helping
folks just like you to get connected
with an elp
endorsed local provider agent text house
to 33789
that's house two three three seven
eight nine all right let's go to steven
in
i just learned this recently louisville
kentucky
steven what's going on man hey how are
you doing today thanks for taking my
call
thank you and i want to i just need to
shout myself out i did not say
louisville
i learned the other it's louisville
louisville it's just a word spilling out
your mouth all right so what's up steven
how can i help man
uh so my wife and i came to decide if we
should fill one vehicle we dropped from
about 90 000 an income down to 65 when
we made the decision to homeschool
and we owe about 20 000 on our last debt
which is student loans
and so tell us your car situation uh
everything's paid off except for the
student loans the
one vehicle is worth about 18 000 and
one is worth about 20.
okay well our our rule of thumb
is to you don't want
things you own with wheels and engines
to be
more than 50 percent of your annual
income
so you're at 65 it's 38
i mean you're kind of like right right
there i mean on on that line steven so
um i don't think the cars are are your
big problem i mean yeah
you don't owe money on them and it's not
this it's not this insane amounts that
you have
you know that have wheels on it sitting
in your driveway that's that seems
unreasonable so i think
if i were you i mean i would just i
think you're fine i think i would just
start
chipping away at that at that 20 grand i
would i mean if you want to sell it
stephen you can
um you know if you're going to get a
discussion we've been having
yeah i don't think it's been on this
video 100 000 so far wow
congrats that's amazing yes
steven hey listen brother you are so
close
you're so close i know and if you have
that taste in your mouth and you both
agree and you're like you know what sell
it we're going to drive a beater
just to be done you can do that
absolutely it's not necessary
um but yeah i mean it's always an option
yep always an option
can your family operate on one vehicle
we can yeah like i say yeah she's a
stay-at-home mom now i'm doing home
school
so uh it could be done or i've got a
company vehicle
well right now my wife's a stay-at-home
mom and
she puts more miles on the car than i do
by my
triple or quadruple right you say you've
got a company vehicle so you actually
have two paid for
cars at home and getting you around
during the day is your company car
correct oh so i'd sell that sucker today
yeah you could do that
okay all right and then you just need to
call kelly
back soon and and you can get on here
and do your debt-free screen
we're looking forward to it how long
have you guys been cracking away at this
thing
honestly i think we've we started out
kind of faith-ish
and uh i think we've been at it for
about five years now
awesome 100 grand y'all y'all have made
a huge stride stephen so congrats
congratulations and i don't want to lose
sight it's allowed them
this close to do something hey let's
stay at home
let's start homeschooling yeah and you
can make these values discussions when
you have decisions we don't have the
money hanging over you so
good for you stephen all right let's go
to alicia in fargo what's up alicia how
are we doing
hi thank you for taking my call thanks
for calling how can we help
um so i will be getting custody of my
six-year-old son
in august and i'm kind of curious
how to adjust our budget
i've been kind of putting a little bit
of money towards some
schooling and stuff getting
certifications for classes so i can
teach doing personal training and
so i'm kind of wondering if i should
like back off on some of that stuff
me and my husband already i had to move
into a different apartment and
so we have you know more expenses where
that's
um you know coming from and then just
like unexpected
expensive having a kid again in the
house
so just like feeling a little anxious
about how it's all going to play out and
you know we've been we're on baby step
two and
we paid off almost half of our debt
within the first year
awesome but then this last yes thank you
um
but this last six months with all these
changes and trying to
invest in a side hustle of sorts um
i've seen that you know that number is
steadily going down and it's kind of
disheartening and you know adding a kid
to the mix
just kind of makes me want to put my you
know my foot on the gas and get this
debt taken care of so i'm
wondering if i should you know stop with
the school stuff
and just you know really focus on
just trying to save money in the budget
what's the custody arrangement are you
you're you say you're taking back full
custody
yeah um so i'm a recovering addict
and when i was using i lost custody of
my son
um about three years ago and i'm
me and my husband we're both two years
clean now we've
totally turned things around um my mom
has my son
and so it's a very cordial arrangement
and
we're just transferring the custody back
to me and my husband will then be
adopting my son
alicia i'm so proud of you it's amazing
amazing thank you
and as a mom i'm like oh getting your
son back i mean what a beauty
like honestly bringing tears to my eyes
because i'm like it's a beautiful
new beginning this like renewal of of
your life and you guys have worked hard
in so many aspects and
and and obviously the the financial side
is why you called but just a bigger
picture alicia like i mean it's just
it it's incredible absolutely incredible
what you guys are doing
um but to you to answer your question on
a tactical level
we find with people getting out of debt
the deeper they're willing to sacrifice
and that's lifestyle that's future
dreams
that's i mean everything the more
they're just like you know what this is
our singular focus
no no distractions nothing we are
getting this paid off
the faster they pay it off obviously
it's a mathematical equation at that
point
um so i think i would i would ask you
you know to look out two
three years to say okay what are your
goals what are you wanting to do you can
could you do the certification in in
nine months
and stop you know pause right now and
pay off this debt get it cleaned out
wiped off um and then be able to build
that life
off of that you know financial
foundation of no debt um do you want to
do both because you're trying to do both
right now and you're feeling the weight
of oh well i'm not making the progress
and it's that disheartening um so i
would say i mean you and your husband i
would i would make that decision as a
family you called the ramsey show so of
course my my knee jerk is like
pause everything and pay that debt off
because you're gonna get so many options
and have that peace of mind
um but that would be that's what i would
do but again you guys talk as a family
and say okay do we want the
certification and it's gonna take a
little bit longer to pay off the debt
um that's a decision you guys would make
and then i would say this to alicia
um as he comes back into your life and
you asked you know about adjusting the
budget
um yeah you will have expenses obviously
having another
member of the family but but be careful
um
not to have the guilt and the shame from
your past
to overcompensate of any of that that
you're feeling
right on buying stuff for him and the
money portion
so so he is how old is he he's six is
that what you said
six yeah so i you know some parents i
know whether it's a divorce
or they're getting custody like this
there's a there's a guilt of i want to
provide this amazing life and they end
up spending so much
out of that and it's a beautiful
motivation but it's out the wrong way so
just
just be aware alicia i've worked with
addicts for my entire career
i want to see you crush this debt i want
you to pause everything i want you
and your husband to go bananas pay this
off
and that victory is going to fuel you
it's going to give you a lift it's going
to take those shame bricks out of your
backpack
and like rachel said i want you to get a
sleeve of tennis balls and go to the
like a local playground
you're gonna have the time of your life
with your kid he's gonna be so excited
to be with mom
so fun you don't need video games you
don't need enough you need some tennis
balls in your heart
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best
deal all right today's question comes
from
nick in michigan i'm considering leaving
my career where i earn 130 000
a year to support my wife's career her
company asked her to relocate for a
better position and we are on board
we currently earn 270 000 a year
have 1.5 million dollars in a net worth
1.3 and investments her income will grow
but it will not fully replace mine and
i'll be a stay-at-home dad if we move
i think we would still be on track to
our future goals and our financial
advisor agrees should we risk should we
take this risk for the betterment
of our family sure
this is not a risk go nick yeah
brother you got 1.5 million dollars and
your wife
she already earns 140 she's gonna let's
say she's gonna earn another hundred
right brother there's nobody starving
this is awesome
yep and you're gonna be a stay-at-home
dad your kids are gonna love um
having you in their life more i think
this is a no-brainer for sure
not even think about it yep i know it
and so what's interesting is i'm like
you know i love this show because you
get calls from
every spectrum of income every spectrum
of walk of life i mean all of it and so
you get the ones that are you know
paying off you know
twenty thousand dollars in debt making
seventeen thousand bumped up to thirty
two you know
and then this is like oh whoa with six
figures we're talking about
um and it's almost like when you get
comfortable in this
in this situation it feels it's so
uncomfortable to kind of shake it up it
feels like a risk because you're like
because you're so used to that amount
but listen nick this is what you guys
have you guys have been working hard
like
you've been doing the right stuff for
this moment for this moment so
now you get to really step out and and
make a change for your family
i man rachel i hadn't thought about that
until just now
this is why having people in your life
is important that
are have are all over the spectrum but
ultimately
live different lives in you because i
think it's easy
to step back
i mean to not step back to get so
involved and i can see him and his wife
sitting there biting their nails saying
hey we had this goal of
5 million sure and all we have now is
1.3 or 1.5 or what
could we do this and you need that buddy
in your life that's like what are you
talking yes
move yesterday what are you doing right
and i it is
fascinating it reminds me of like the
golden handcuffs
mentality right absolutely you're
getting paid well
life is real good and if we take off
but but yet i'm stuck i'm stuck in a
life i don't really want like the way he
says it's like oh
the betterment of our family would be to
make this move and my wife is so excited
her position i get to see him dad like
it's all
positive but these golden handcuffs keep
us in a position
just because of the money and life is so
much more than that you know
in any time you start a question with or
in the question with
dot dot dot for the betterment of our
family you're probably on the right
track
yeah right whatever this thing is going
to be if it's going to make your family
better
rachel i want to touch on this right at
the break james was giving me a hard
time at the break
because i ended the call with all your
kid really wants is your heart
and some tennis balls man i want to just
spend time with you and i realized i
said that kind of dumb
um but you've written a book on
contentment and so this last call is
about
hey man we lost custody of our kid we
are
moving to a another apartment and we are
grinding
and i'm about to get my kid back after
all of this stuff
all this shame all this climate and claw
and scratching
it's the same sentiment to this call
which is
hey should i take a 30 000 130
000 pay cut i'm gonna change my identity
become a stay home dad
for this 275 it all comes back to this
idea of comparison and contentment
what's best for us right
you wrote a book on that parents trying
to say oh do we have a nasty have enough
and then you've got this
this we've we've talked to parent after
parent who's like i just need to buy my
kids
perfection i need to make up for what
was talk to folks who struggle with that
i that i'm only as good as my
ability to keep up with my neighbors
what everyone else is doing right yeah
i mean oh gosh it's it's a rat and a
wheel mentality that's always the
picture i have cause i'm like you just
run run run run run after something and
you get
nowhere nowhere you get nowhere and
sadly this is our culture like this is
the area this is the country we live in
where it's like stuff the bigger the
better
the upgrade that's what you i mean it's
just and you run and you run and you get
the upgrade you buy the bigger thing
and you just keep on going it's like
this race that never ends and you never
gain traction and
and it's sad because it steals the
beauty of of your life and your
relationships and all of that and
in this show you know we talk about
money management to
to get you to a point people that are
listening to say okay i don't want money
to control me money controls me in so
many ways whether it's emotional whether
it's
debt it's my choices my money is telling
me what to do and to
flip that on its end and say no i'm
gonna control my money
i'm gonna make a plan and get out of
debt i'm gonna live on a budget so my
money doesn't tell me what to do i'm
going to do these things to set myself
up where money's on an idol where my
stuff isn't an idol
um and that's the beauty of it like that
that's the part of the journey
that you have to take on so it's the
math side yes we say it all the time
but gosh that that emotional side can be
as damaging and then you throw kids into
the mix
we've we've just been dealing with this
at our house my son came came home and
he's in fifth grade dad i'm the only kid
in my class without filling the blank
a cell phone and a tick tock account and
and and
and luckily his mom and i have been
telling him for years
because we knew this was coming hey
we're gonna we're gonna go ahead and
tell you up front your parents are weird
and we're
we're sorry but not sorry right and feel
free to tell your friends i don't have
any of that stuff because my parents are
lame you can use us
but at the end of the day man your kids
don't want
stuff they just want you yes right
you can go to walmart and get a 19 zebco
man it goes spend every saturday for the
childhood
and they're gonna man that's so much
more valuable than the next xbox and the
next thing
right but it's so hard and rachel it's
been my experience
mom's got this way worse yeah as we look
at each other at the baseball field
but you know like and i might think that
baseball bats 400 dollars like that's a
lot
he's gonna grow out of it in a week but
there's an industry
designed to keep moms from having stable
feed on the sidewalk right
to keep it oh wow so much so much that's
that's against it and and
and what's funny too is i'm like you
know our kids
are so much like adults like i learned
so much from my kids and
you know amelia will say oh her new
thing and i
i'm like makes you cringe a little bit
but she does she's like i'm bored
i'm bored and and we have a play room
full of toys i've been in it it's it's
the size of my home
no no it's not that big but like there
is a in my head i'm like there's a
playroom there's a garage with bikes
and stuff you know i mean like there are
stuff to do but i look at her i'm like
i'm so glad you're bored now you're
forced to figure out something this is a
you now get to use your mind and do
something different now
but as adults that's what we do oh i'm
bored i need to go on amazon and buy
something and
you know what i'm saying like how often
we say we may not say it verbally
but our emotions are that and that
causes that emotional spending too so we
just have to watch
that stuffitus that's what that's what
dad would say but it is i'm like it
it's a thing that we think is gonna
fulfill and
cause contentment and it does the
opposite i even saw somebody um
yesterday
and they're probably working on this
right now so you know who you are
um was just looking at homes on a
computer
i said are you moving no i moved like
four or five years ago i'm just i'm just
checking out this
and i was thinking see what's going on i
i did that so much right
just to see what's the neighbor's house
and how's this gonna be but it just
becomes more stuff
and it's so i i fight it rachel i fight
it
but you buy this thing and you're like
okay i'm just gonna hang on to this for
a few years so that i can
instead of just enjoying this thing that
i got right right
it's so good right my home gym this is
good now until i can one day i'm gonna
build this thing this thing over here
uh-huh uh-huh it's a pretty good gym man
it's pretty good and rachel's you got a
gym
super atomic minivan that can basically
it's basically a spacex minivan
all i hear is about but one day the
tesla right rachel i know i do it too
man tastes like vinegar
do you know that movie name that movie
the blind side
anyone sorry i was too i'm too busy
playing with my kids to watch movies
yeah tastes like vinegar
tastes like vinegar america we'll be
right back this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is from
numbers chapter 6 verses 24-26
the lord bless you and keep you the lord
make his face shine on you and be
gracious to you
the lord turn his face towards you and
give you
peace arthur ash says start where you
are use what you have
do what you can
man rachel that makes me think of the
the debt-free caller from earlier today
seventeen thousand dollars is what her
annual income was and she says
we start today yep we start today and
then eleven months later
she's almost making double she crushed
it it's awesome let's go out to green
bay wisconsin and talk to ayonda
what is going on ayanda how are we doing
good thank you how are you guys doing
we're doing so good how can we help
thank you so much for taking my phone
call my question
for today was my husband and i
are currently on baby steps four five
and six
and so we are investing our 15
as well as getting a match um from both
of the places we work at
which adds up to about 12 percent extra
wow
yeah thank you and we also um have five
29's for three of our kids they aged
one three and five that we're putting
into and then we pay
obviously our mortgage and we've been
doing extra payments
but still at the end of the month we
have close to
about 2000 that gets left over
in our budget and so my question was
um do we throw more
money on top of the extra money of the
mortgage that we're doing
or could we actually start maybe looking
at like
investing that extra money we have left
over in the month
so that was kind of like my question or
our dilemma at the moment what do you
guys do for a living you're
crushing it sure
my husband's in sales i was and i was
actually a stay-at-home mom
for a while and then the last two years
i actually picked up three part-time
jobs
wow what yeah what's that what was the
motivation for that to get moving
financially or just you just wanted to
fill your time
sure yeah so um our kids are actually
aged one three and five
so um last year i actually called in
and we were on baby step two and i got
to speak to dave
and we only had our car payments
that we had and right after i got off
the phone we had an emergency fund
and i just we just paid that off
immediately we're like okay
and then we just kind of got moving
after that so we kind of
have an emergency fund of about eight
months that we've got
enough yeah wow great job right now
great job incredible
and so you're investing you said 12
no 15 and the companies additional okay
okay i got you
um so that's 27 of your income is being
invested right now
yes um towards our retirement and i
think we have about
and fifty in total at the moment okay
that's in
february in our retirement and that
percentage does that include the
employer's match
no so the 15 is just
what we put in of our income okay and
then
um the match comes in my husband's
company that actually has
he's got better benefits but they match
him ten percent
at his job so that's so that's there
okay so you guys are sticking to that 15
of your own income yeah perfect yeah so
beyond that i mean honestly i would i
would throw the extra at the mortgage
for sure i think that
that 15 is gonna get you guys in a great
spot
uh when you reach retirement you'll be
able to bulk up your investing
even more after that mortgage is paid
off so i would get that house paid off
as quickly as possible which you guys
are doing which is awesome
and i'll say this too because i'm the
spender of the ramsey personalities
is that you can breathe a little too you
guys are you guys are in a great
position you know we say to have
you know the pedal down real real fast
on
baby steps one through three lots of
sacrifice a lot like you said you got
your three part-time jobs and you are
just busting it
and then once you have that emergency on
where you guys are at you can you can
take a little bit of a deep breath you
can enjoy
enjoy some life so just remember that
but if you do have that consistent
income at the end of the month that
you're saying you don't have a budget
for it then yes the answer would be
throw it at the mortgage
okay all right thank you so much yes we
were kind of
looking for and trying to see um because
in all of this
um he gets paid a bonus at the end of
the year that we just kind of throw a
lump sum
towards the mortgage i love it oh you
got yeah
kill it that's amazing it's amazing dave
said this the other day we were when i
was on the show with him
and i actually wrote it down and went
home and my wife and i planned a
vacation
so i i've become you know we bought a
house earlier this year
rachel i hate owning owing people money
drives me crazy
and so we have been treating our house
payment as though we're in
emergency step one right let's whatever
extra pennies we have and um
dave's line was that those first few
baby steps you got to be
intense yeah and then the other ones got
to be intentional
but you got to live right yes yes i'm
always telling people to live and i
thought
what am i doing man we at least got to
go have some memories right so totally
totally
we're going to get away for we're going
to take an afternoon this year just
kidding
we're going to go i'm going to take two
hours off before that's right let's take
the kids to mcdonald's and we're going
to call it
all right let's go to bridgette in
columbia falls what's going on bridget
how are we doing
hi guys i'm so excited to talk to you
and actually
while i've been on hold i just got a job
offer which was part of my question oh
my gosh that's amazing
see you don't even have to talk to us
just get on the line and we'll save your
life
well congratulations is this a good job
are you excited about it or what
yeah actually i was really worried
because um
right now we're just on my husband's
income and we're on baby step 3b
and i was working kind of part-time
seasonal jobs
and i decided i was like i really need a
bigger shovel if we're going to do this
so i applied for a bigger job
but of course those always take longer
so it's like then two and a half weeks
and being on one income where we live
we're in a destination area so
our our bills are a little bit more so
it's definitely really tight
so i was feeling kind of desperate
actually on the call
and then i got a phone call about the
job offer because i was
i was like shoot i just need to make
cash now and i have a side business
that i'm trying to kick off the ground
that's in sales it's in
health and wellness is health coaching
but obviously that takes longer than you
think
so yeah so actually i um
after this call i'm driving down for an
impromptu interview
for a different position but yeah so
great do you have a question now or did
it get answered because you got the
the offer i think it got answered
because i got the offer okay there you
go
well it was so great to talk to you yeah
exactly we'll be the first to
congratulate you yeah congrats
and i think that's the lesson for
america yeah i think
actually rachel that may be the best
thing we've done all day
i think our advice isn't super great but
man if you can hang on the line
and uh click over and get a job
opportunity your life can change
if you can get connected to kelly in any
shape form or fashion
that's what you need to do and get
through there and by the way
it wouldn't be a good idea if we let the
day go it is kelly's birthday
we're excited that she's turning 21
today this is a big day
it's gonna feel weird buying lottery
tickets on your way home don't do it
kelly
don't do it but we are excited for you
so funny no seriously how old are you
she's not listening she's not listening
how old are you kelly 63
i didn't hear what you said oh my gosh i
was getting oh i was gonna say you're a
beautiful 63 but you're 47. okay
jeez i thought well i said kelly
you look like i mean i literally if i
were to guess i would have thought
for sure early 40s see i would have i
would have thought 33
max capital max oh my goodness
and james your birthday was yesterday it
was
yeah he's 72. was it i don't know
oh yeah we don't know but now the
internet's no james
hey by the way james well i've got you i
want to thank you for a great show today
kelly happy birthday thank you kelly for
joining us
rachel as always is super fun and to
everyone listening
thank you for joining us treat each
other kindly be
nice say you're sorry and do your best
to get out of debt
this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you